sally's to tell author of PC MD if you
saw on your television set that Deepak
Chopra or Andrew Weil or Kristine
Northrup we're going to appear what
would your reaction be well I guess it
would depend on what show they were
going to appear if it was a show about
alternative medicine and about new New
Age philosophy in medicine I think that
they were perfect representatives
otherwise I don't feel that they really
represent clinical approaches or ideas
about illness that are grounded in
science well you can see them on a
regular basis on public television first
of all what do you know about any of
them I know that Christiane Northrup did
in fact have a PBS special and she wrote
a book called women's bodies my gosh I'm
blanking on it but and it
she had wide wide viewership in fact all
three of them Deepak Chopra and I
believe Andrew Weil as well have had
specials on PBS so that's a huge
viewership in their books our
bestsellers so clearly they appeal to
people but some of the messages that
they put out I think are as I said not
really grounded in an experimental work
they talk about therapies that have not
been proven and Christiane Northrup in
particular has put forth as a women's
health expert and yet some of the some
of the truisms that she was putting
forth reminded me of some of a bad
parody of Freud and what she said for
example was that certain kinds of
emotional states can cause thyroid
illness or cancer or blood clots this
sort of thing and we have no evidence of
that so what would she say if she were
here that's a good question I know in
her book she she consulted something
called a person called a medical
intuitive and this is someone without
any real clinical training but can
examine your your body or your aura and
tell you what kinds of
as your body has registered and in fact
in her case she said her body had
registered a rape between ages 20 and 25
and she thought back well that's when I
was in medical school and I know I
wasn't raped that we shouldn't invoke
the repressed memory but maybe I was
traumatized or violated in some way and
her interpretation was that she had been
mistreated by her male colleagues or
somehow oppressed during her training I
mean she believes this obviously her
book was uneven because in fact there
were some things in it that I thought
were quite accurate she had a good
discussion for example of silicone
breast implants which was was accurate
and I thought the advice she gave to
women was well informed so it was it's
uneven why do the the three of them
selves probably millions of books and
people watch their programs and go to
their events and lectures yeah I think
there's a great investment really in
romanticism about health I think people
want to feel that they are in control
and a lot of ways I think they are in
control in terms of diet and exercise
the kinds of things we know we can do
but there is a mystical a dimension that
these folks bring in and I think that
that it appeals to people who perhaps
aren't especially scientifically
literate I mean that's a problem we have
today we know that alternative medicine
is very popular and there are several
reasons for that
one is that it it might actually appear
to work in many cases and the reason for
that is that most conditions for which
people go to doctors are actually time
limited they do go away by themselves so
that if you were to take Saint John's
wort for depression or some other kind
of health food store remedy and it
appeared to work it's often because it
was a time-limited event to begin with
also we know that alternative
practitioners are famous for spending
more time with with patients and that's
something unfortunately in an era of
managed care that conventional
physicians can't often do
and we also know that there is something
called the placebo effect it's not that
powerful when it comes to severe
conditions like like cancer but for
emotional problems and from minor
illnesses that can be mediated through
stress that can be very powerful so
there is there's ample reason why people
might believe that it actually works but
I know that if I had cancer I certainly
would not go to Andrew Weil what is the
placebo effect Sasebo effect is when a
person experiences some relief when
they're given a medication or some sort
of intervention it doesn't have to be
medication it could be some process
called therapeutic touch which is very
popular now which effect you're not even
touched the idea is that a apocryphal
energy field that surrounds you as being
smooth out and this will promote healing
but that when some sort of healing
intervention is offered to an individual
they may experience relief and sometimes
that relief is even measurable for
example that they they they might be
sweating less if they're very anxious
but in fact there was no what we call
active ingredient in that kind of a
sugar pill and it's it can be very
powerful and it's not all suggestion
although some of it is suggestion of
course probably the idea that one is
being cared for soothed by another
person just that variant that human
interaction you can meet it can be
mediated through our stress system
through the hormonal system that itself
can have effects on cardiovascular
activity and our immune system so it's
it's a very interesting phenomenon and
it fact it is being studied and would be
interesting to harness that where did
you go to med school and when I went to
medical school between 1980 and 84 I
graduated from Brown University School
of Medicine why did you go to med school
well I went to medical school actually I
I experienced an illness and I had a bad
illness after undergrad and it was an
infection and a very common treatment
for that infection was steroid
medications not not the kind of steroids
that bodybuilder take bodybuilders take
not anabolic steroids but what's called
catabolic steroids or a prednisone a
common one that people probably heard of
and it was very effective I was on a
high dose and it turned out that I got
profoundly depressed from taking that
medication when the medication was
tapered off and it's a medication effect
you can't stop abruptly you have to
taper it off then I was fine but it was
really a transforming experience for me
because I had I mean everyone
experiences you know blues now and then
but I never I never experienced a such a
profound and desolate kind of depression
and as I said thank goodness it was time
limited but it made me realize that
there are people who are suffering with
what we call endogenous depression it's
not caused by some chemical they took or
some some medication side effect that
it's essentially their own
neurotransmitters revolting it's
something that was a part of them and I
thought that was such a harrowing
experience for me yet such a relief that
it could be turned off by taking this
this Medicare this prednisone away but
that there were people for whom that
couldn't be the explanation and this was
something they had a worry about perhaps
returning because as we know depression
can be a recurring phenomenon and so I
decided I wanted to go into psychiatry
and that's why I went to medical school
where did you gone to your undergrad
Cornell or was home originally Queens
New York any medicine in your family no
none my parents neither than had gone to
college so there you are
psychiatry was the subject did you go
when you get us a cottage degree do you
have to get a medical doctor degree
first yeah you have to go through four
years of medical school and then there's
a residency period
pretty much everyone does an internship
which is a
in my case was a general medical
internship so I had a year in st.
Raphael's hospital in New Haven of being
a real doctor you know doing surgery for
two months internal medicine for about
eight months and it's just essential to
forming your identity as a physician and
of course learning invaluable physiology
and clinical techniques and where did
you go then we get a little bit of your
work history since you got out of med
school graduated medical school K 84
then of course I did this then I did the
internship then you do three years of
residency so that's four years total
post graduate what you do did that it at
Yale and I thought I was going to go on
and do research and become an academic
psychiatrist and do research in
schizophrenia I've always found that to
be the most fascinating and really
tragic of all mental illnesses but it
turned out that if one we're going to
pursue that in an academic setting there
were really two main kinds of research
paths one could follow one was
neuroscience either in the lab or what
now we know as PET imaging you know
functional imaging of the brain but
pretty strict neuroscience or what's
called services research something that
is not really that patient near where
you look at the best ways to provide
services to patients basically and and
in hospital settings and clinic settings
and that seemed too sterile to me even
though it's very important work so what
I was really interested in it was
descriptive psychiatry or phenomenology
and in schizophrenia a lot of that had
been done in the late 1800s so there
wasn't that much opportunity so right
around that time the early the mid 80s
crack had come on the scene and it was
assumed that crack would induce the same
sort of mental status changes in in
addicts and drug users that
methamphetamine did you know speed kills
Speed Freaks back from the 50s and 60s
and so it was assumed that we would see
a lot of cocaine and do psychosis and I
thought well that's an inch
stay away to study thought disorder
which was the essence of schizophrenia
that I was interested in I'll do it by
studying drunk drug addicts and it
turned and I did and so I became an
expert in addiction but it turned out
that cocaine did not produce the same
kind of psychosis and psychiatric
symptoms that that methamphetamine did
is quite interesting actually what it
what it could produce in a subset of
people if they'd taken a high enough
dose was a kind of time-limited paranoia
as opposed to a full-fledged psychotic
profile of hallucinations and delusions
that was seen as some meth have heavy
methamphetamine the speed users so that
that was one of those sort of my early
research career and coke where did you
go to do this I did at the West Haven VA
in near Yale yes associated with Yale
meth and feta mean is what what's it
look like well it could look like a
powder I mean it comes in pills I mean
it used to come in pills just you know
you can still get I think decks are all
in the index dexedrine and the pharmacy
but but methamphetamine is made now and
clandestine labs and it looks powdery
what do you do people who inject it
that's called crank sometimes you know
that needling engine yeah you can inject
it with a needle and you can also
crystallize it as they as one duck can
do with cocaine and smoke that and it's
it's highly addicting and it's even more
dangerous than crack because it's more
neurotoxic so you can really do
neurological damage that lasts and it
produces a more intense derangement and
you read in the newspaper these horrific
crimes of fathers decapitating their
sons I remember this and I mean horrible
murders I think Karla Faye Tucker
actually committed her murders while on
speed
what about crack what is that what's
that look like
crack is cocaine it looks exactly like
if you take hard candy a pineapple hard
candy from lifesavers and spend and
hammer it you'll get little pieces that
look exactly like
and the reason I know that that's a good
good visual substitute is because we did
some research on trying to induce
craving at the West Haven VA craving for
crack in crack addicts and see if we
could blunt it with certain medications
so so you went from there at New Haven
to where well and 90 in 92 I applied for
something called the Robert Wood Johnson
health policy fellowship because after
nine years in New Haven I thought I
wanted to move on
and I also was getting a little bit
frustrated working at the VA now that's
not a particularly new reaction you
doctors who work at the VA it's a it's a
special kind of an institution in fact
it's almost more of a social institution
than a medical institution for a lot of
these patients and my patients a lot of
them were Vietnam veterans were using
the benefit money that they got from
being service-connected to buy their
drugs now here I was running a drug
treatment unit and yet the my patients
and my efforts were being undermined by
the very benefits that these men were
getting because they would they would
use it to finance their habits now I'm
certainly not saying they didn't deserve
those benefits these are
service-connected benefits if someone's
a hundred percent service-connected they
could get up to two thousand a month
tax-free that's quite a lot of money and
I don't mean to imply for a minute it
wasn't deserved
obviously they risk their lives but it
was certainly holding them back and a
number of the other patients not
everyone in a VA gets veterans benefits
some of the patients also got SSI the
Supplemental Security income and
Supplemental Security income up until
1995 actually recognized addiction as a
disability so people could get income
maintenance by virtue of being an addict
in other words by virtue of being so
intoxicated that they couldn't work and
again I thought this was a perverse
incentive
I kept financing patients habits
and also they knew that if they got
better that income would cease so it was
a very very regressive kind of thing and
I thought there there had to be ways to
use these benefits so that we could
essentially use them as an incentive to
recovery as opposed to almost an
inducement to stay sick and
dysfunctional I also realized that I
couldn't do that as one person
frequently I'd say to the patients you
know if well me we could have access to
your money and control it for you it
would really help you a lot and they'd
agree with me all the time and then tell
me they would break that my legs if I
tried so I appreciated their honesty of
course but I knew that if when we're
going to reform these kinds of systems
and and give out benefits in a way that
that was constructive for patients as
opposed to you know keeping them them
mired in destructive behaviors this had
to come at either administrative level
or some some larger level it couldn't
come from me at the VA so I applied for
this health policy fellowship to see if
there was any way to influence thinking
about disability benefits to people with
mental illness and especially to people
with addiction problems know when did
you get to San Francisco
I never wasn't Sanford I thought I read
in your book that you were you did
something out there and now I didn't
actually a book reviewer another
reviewer misinterpreted that as well so
maybe it wasn't written that clearly in
the book what I was referring to I never
was in San Francisco but what I was
referring to was actually one of my
first encounters with what I call
politically correct medicine and it was
about something going on at San
Francisco General Hospital how did you
find that how did you come in contact
with it I found out about it because a
colleague of mine had been in a meeting
sponsored by the American Psychiatric
Association and there they were
discussing something called
multicultural treatment and San
Francisco General Hospital was a place
in which this was very avid Lee endorsed
and as the more he told me about it the
more I I was stunned basically what was
going on there and what's still going on
there
is a division of the inpatient unit the
psychiatric inpatient units in San
Francisco general are divided up by by
race essentially its identity politics
moving into psychiatry there's a black
unit it's called the black focus unit
there's a unit for hiv-positive patients
one for Asians Hispanics and women none
for white men Brian so I why what do you
think of this I think that it's perverse
I think that when it started out in the
70s it started out with two specialty
units one for Asians and one for
Hispanics and at that time it made
perfect sense because there were a lot
of uh Nicole Charita dimma grens they
didn't speak the language it made the
most sense to have a unit that had
doctors and nurses who spoke the
language and other patients who also
understood the customs and again spoke
the language to be together and that
would enhance treatment and that made
perfect sense but when special units for
gay patients for gay schizophrenics for
black schizophrenic
for example started to be formed I
thought that the the clinical imperative
was giving way to basically victim
politics and in fact I did interview
some of the folks involved with the San
Francisco project and the rationale for
it it did seem to me that it was in the
best interest of patients at all I mean
the idea behind the black focus unit for
example was that in order for patients
to to readjust in order to to go back
out in the community and and live more
productively they had to really come to
terms with the fact that they were
victims of racism and much of the staff
training focused on that many of the
groups for patients focused on that it
turned out though after a few years
there was so much rancor and so much
almost paranoia among the staff about
race politics that it became an
inhospitable environment for white
trainees so now it's it's one of the few
units that
francisco general which is a major
teaching hospital at university of san
francisco medical school that doesn't
have any trainees because the the
environment the milieu just got too
touchy that that's not healthy for
patients and ironically now again in
this age of managed care and you know
efforts to keep cost down patients are
in they come in very sick some of them
are committed i mean they're literally
forced against their will because
they're so psychotic they really don't
even know are dangerous to themselves or
others they have to be essentially
committed and they're there for such a
short period of time that there's really
only enough time to stabilize them on
medication so in a sense it becomes moot
i think at this point but the philosophy
behind it that that that basically we
have to treat member patients as members
of victim groups rather than as
individuals who are suffering is a very
destructive trend to me and in fact one
that's becoming quite popular in the
counseling profession and that's where
multicultural counseling it didn't make
that term up he's taking off it's
endorsed by the American counseling
Association I went to their meeting last
year and that was one of the effect that
was the theme of the meeting diversity
and multicultural counseling and it's
very very pernicious there are three
basic tenets to multicultural counseling
and I must say this is not done with
people who are wildly psychotic it's
done with people who have problems of
living difficulty adjusting minor
depression or anxiety but the three
tenets of multicultural therapy are
first that the Thera that the therapist
the counselor assumes that the most
important aspect of a patient's
psychological landscape is his or her
membership in an oppressed group assumes
that the second is that whatever
distress this patient is suffering from
is inevitably due to his or her bumping
up against racism sexism or some sort of
oppressive force and thirdly that for
the patient to get better he or she will
have to engage in some sort of social
activism which only makes sense of
course if you believe that it's the
environment that's that's largely
responsible for your psychic
stress then that's going to be the
that's got to be the thing that you seek
to change now when you think about it
this is the antithesis of therapy
therapy should be about self observation
it should be about taking responsibility
for choices it it really is often a good
psychotherapy it's about learning how
people how an individual unwittingly
sabotages himself and you have a student
who thinks he wants to be go to medical
school and you have to wonder then why
did he miss his MCAT exam and why is he
you know fail organic chemistry and that
sort of thing and and that's very a very
rich source of neuroses as we say to
mine but it's not about blaming it's not
about externalizing it's about looking
looking inside and you can't do that if
you're focusing on oppressive forces
when did you first come to Washington
1993 through that fellowship the Robert
Wood Johnson Health Policy how long did
you do that that was about a year I
worked with senator Nancy Kassebaum
understand yeah on the on her committee
staff she was the ranking member on the
Health and Human Services waiver and
Human Services staff had you been
political before you got to this
situation and do you consider yourself
political today no I'd never been
political at all I never voted until 92
and no I never was using a your attire
but PC MD politically correct MD I
understand and when I in fact when I
went to work for senator Kassebaum I
went to work with her because the Robert
Wood Johnson fellowship had the fellows
in that fellowship had been going on
since the 70s had so routinely worked
for Democrats so they just begged
somebody to go with a Republican and I
thought well okay I will it turned out
to be the most magnificent experience
and I guess I did become somewhat poeta
sized after it I switched parties and
during the Republican Party
but did you work you at someone you
worked in in DC here in what a clinic
yes I worked since 95 I've been working
in clinics I work now in a methadone
clinic where in DC it's the Northeast
it's about 2 miles on the other side of
the Capitol down on Maryland Avenue and
what do you find when you go there what
kind of folks are in the methadone
clinic well our clinic is mainly for
working poor
we do have maybe a 25% Medicaid
population but mainly it's people who
pay for their methadone and who hold
down jobs
what's the racial mix I want to say
about 5050 the staff is almost all
african-american but the and the doctor
who owns it is african-american because
you write a lot about race in your book
and what's going on in PC MD medicine on
all this do you see much racism in your
clinic no I see no I don't see much too
much racial politics in my not is it not
as far as the relationship between the
the counselors and and me and the
patients go you see a lot of what you're
talking about in your book in the
clubbing actually what I see yes when I
talk about my book is really an effort
to well the book is it's really an
expose of what I call political
correctness in medicine the the idea
that disease and even behavioral
dysfunction are primarily caused by
social injustice and that doctors and
especially public health professionals
should take on social justice as a
mission I I reject that but that's
that's this trend I call political
correctness and I and I see it in many
venues I don't see it in my clinic in
fact I describe to some of the
counselors there the the multicultural
therapy that I saw going on at another
DC clinic that I did work in and they
thought it was bizarre and where is that
oh that was with the DC Superior Court
it's since been
we re it's since been shut down and
started up again and I and I think a
more healthy and a clinically productive
way what was going on there and what did
you do there that's different than where
you are with this method online at this
clinic I worked in as I said it was part
of the DC Superior Court so our patients
were were court-ordered
in fact the context was something called
it a drug court let's just explain that
to you very briefly drug court they're
not very popular they're about 500 them
across the country they started in 1989
and the idea is to divert nonviolent
addict offenders into treatment to try
to distinguish between the criminal
addict and the addicted criminal and
take the person who but for a habbit
wouldn't have committed a minor crime
and not incarcerate them but send them
to treatment and I'm all in favor of
that in fact I know from my own
experience and from a lot of research
I've done that that kind of coerced
treatment works especially well because
it ensures retention and treatment
programs and we know that's the best
predictor of outcome well that said DC
had a drug court and but the clinic
which I went to work in a 95 was
inhabited by counselors who did endorse
this multicultural approach and that's
how I first became aware of it and so we
had our patients almost exclusively
black men in their 20s and 30s the
majority of them were functionally
illiterate few of them had high school
diplomas let alone GEDs they didn't have
much experience than the legitimate
workforce and we could have done so much
for them as I said wheat they were our
captives we had them five hours a day
for a minimum of nine months we could
have set them up with apprenticeships
and and GED courses but instead they
spent hours in groups being a counselor
led groups in which they were inculcated
in their a victimhood they were they
were they were talking about racism and
how you were oppressed black men one day
I came in and they were doing art
therapy coloring and stencils of the
African continent in
a spirit of ethnic self pride and the
patient's themselves that this isn't a
tragedy the patient's themselves thought
this was a terrible waste of their time
who's teaching them that whiter blacks
in the psychiatrist there are no
psychiatrist No thank goodness this
hasn't seeped too far into psychiatry
psychiatrists and psychologists are
still among the most sophisticated
mental health professionals you know if
you imagine sort of a pyramid like this
in terms of number ends and training
psychiatrists at the very top
psychologists close up there then the
social workers another band and then at
the bottom counselors who some of them
are excellent I worked with some of the
most wonderful counsellors a lot of them
have had the advantage of course of
being addicts themselves so they have
enormous experience and having had had
that you know lived through it and
recovered and they've also got some some
technical training and they some of them
have been the most wonderful but others
and those were the ones I worked with a
95 I can't say that that they were the
most wonderful and you learned this in
schools of counselling if you love it
give us an example where you learn us oh
you can learn it at the University of
Connecticut at Bridgeport
you can learn it at the University of
Oregon any any school that has a
department and counseling that gives
graduate degrees in counseling has
either a offers either courses or a
concentration in multicultural therapy
how did you come about I mean seeing all
this up close I mean your were you the
only psychiatrist at the Superior Court
yes how many people were there total
emissions on a given day how big a
facility was this I want to say about
150 where was it located it was located
on F Street up there near the judiciary
square metro station and you would come
to work every day to do what what was
your job my job was to do intakes on
people basically it's the equivalent of
a physical
an admission physical this would be a
sort of an admission Mental Status exam
and typically they were negative in
other words we didn't have patients by
and large who were actively
hallucinating or suicidal I mean most of
them were drunk you know drug abusers
what and go back to the what were they
the business about filling in Africa or
coloring in Africa how did that come
down why were they do that that's just
one of the exercises that teach him what
ethnic self pride I mean III as a
skeptical as you are and didn't work I
mean was there anything no there wasn't
any there was was there any follow up no
but the patient's themselves were were
really quite distraught over this they
felt that it was a complete waste of
their time you could almost argue it's
not so much what they were doing is what
they were not doing doing the kinds of
things that would help these people be
employable and moderately educated the
the to really the to advances that these
folks could make that would inoculate
them at least somewhat against relapse
to drugs and crime does this book come
out of that experience that is that the
first reason you thought about writing a
book like this that was the first reason
and when did you think I mean how long
has this book been in there in the
making well probably since then I
started writing about this multicultural
therapy then I then about a year later I
became interested in a report that got a
lot of media coverage of the notion that
African Americans were more likely to
suffer from high blood pressure which is
true they are about twice as likely but
that the reason for this as discovered
by a professor at Harvard School of
Public Health and published in the
American Journal of Public Health was
because they suffered the stress of
being discriminated against
this effort busan no but he is there he
is there he is
and and he is he had the same theory
that racism causes hypertension he might
have that theory I know that he is in
favor of considering racism a mental
illness he written a book about that
recently and he had an op-ed I remember
in the New York Times
right after Beauford furrow that white I
believe he may have had white
supremacist ties in LA a few summers ago
shot some in a synagogue and then killed
an Asian man I believe and that prompted
him to write the OP in and the times
that that racism should be considered a
mental illness and in fact that was
brought before the American Psychiatric
Association once I believe in the 70s
and and and he I believe he was part of
the the effort to have the APA
designated as such and put it in the DSM
at that time a BDSM one the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual though the
handbook of diagnosis they rejected that
is there any proof that you know of that
that on this question about racism that
causes physical reaction on the part of
anybody that's not of the white race
sure well I have there's no question in
my mind that any kind of stressful
situation can cause a physiological
response I mean we've known that for for
ages I mean stress causes changes in the
immunes can cause actually changes in
the immune system usually prolong stress
but certainly can lead to blood pressure
elevation hormonal changes that that's
that's there's nothing new about that
but when one looked at her data which
the data of the professor at Harvard who
was concluded that the distress of
discrimination was responsible for this
disparity and high blood pressure when
you look at the data they didn't hold up
there in a in a nutshell she sought to
measure discrimination which is hard to
do admit it let it's a very hard thing
to do her scale was
zero in other words they asked about
four they'd a good sample size about
4,000 patients and asked them and these
were patients fairly young patients who
were going to a kaiser clinic I think in
California somewhere ask them have you
ever been discriminated against in your
life so zero was one designation one or
two times and three or more
those were the three categories let's
just stipulate that the responses were
meaningful but once what they found
she and her colleague were that you
didn't see the kind of direct
relationship the kind of positive
relationship you would expect which is
to say that the the level of blood
pressure would would track with the
report of reports of discrimination so
that those who said they were not
discriminated against would have the
least blood pressure lower blood
pressure readings and so on
you just find that at all I think in
black men you found a negative
correlation in other words those
reporting no discrimination had the
highest readings among women I there was
something called a u-shaped curve where
those who said they had no
discrimination had the highest blood
pressure those who said they had three
or more had the highest but those with
to one or two have an intermediate
anyway it was all over the map and what
most researchers would conclude from
that kind of distribution of data it was
that there is no correlation but instead
what these researchers invoked was
something called internalized oppression
the idea being that that the folks who
claimed to have no experiences of
discrimination really did but that
either they didn't register it
consciously as discrimination because
that's so they had such a low self
regard that that they felt this was just
acceptable behavior this is the way we
should be treated in society hence
internalized oppression you know didn't
even register as an aberrant event or
perhaps they found it too painful to
report these were the explanations but
that's not a falsifiable explanation in
other words it can be it can be invoked
to explain anything so it's not really
typically rigorous define some of the
terms you write about what's that
endocrinologist well that is a term that
that I made up actually a patient of
mine made it up he said he was going to
the endocrinologist but he garbled it in
such a way it was a great neologism and
I thought this really fits these folks
so so it's a word that I coined to to
describe public health professors and
other health professionals who feel that
our health is so completely at the mercy
of social forces that they really there
really is little people can do to
safeguard their health and and
accordingly that the effort of of health
professionals really should be to
encompass social justice and in fact the
former dean of the Harvard School of
Public Health in schools of public
health in general really are ground zero
of this movement was quoted as saying a
school of Public Health is like a school
of justice the American Public Health
Association is quite politicized they
have lots of policy statements some of
them make perfect sense they talk about
lead exposure and good policies for for
preventing that but they also have
policy statements on campaign finance
reform and on the war in Nicaragua and
earned income tax credits and this
certainly is moving away from the
fundamental mission of public health
which is developing the scientific and
practical basis of disease and injury
prevention
what's a consumer-survivor consumer is
the politically correct word for
psychiatric patient consumer yes in fact
a politically correct among what group
among mike some of my colleagues
certainly among the folks who run the
center for mental health services which
is a part of HHS that gives out the
Block Grant for mental state mental
health funding certainly among advocates
for the mentally ill the word consumer
is basically an effort to negate the
hierarchy really between the doctor and
the patient
that unfortunately this is has come to
be seen as by some of them and a kind of
malignant relationship with the powerful
clinician who was somehow oppressing the
helpless patient it's it's a very
distressing worldview that's consumer
but consumer-survivor is a special
species of consumer and the survivor is
not one who has survived schizophrenia
as a breast cancer survivor but one who
has survived mental health services who
how many of them that's a very good
question I tried very hard to get a
count I'm going to say a few hundred and
you might think so why are they
important if they're just a few hundred
of them but they're fairly well
organized these are former mental
patients actually and you have to wonder
how sick they really are if they could
organize so well they frequently work
with the civil liberties lawyers and
they are the most radical of them are
variant lis anti-psychiatry they feel
that the system has actually made them
sick
that it's been wholly a response in
responsive to them and their goal in
fact there are two two goals that they
share one is to either obliterate the
system altogether depending on who you
talk to but the other is to infiltrate
the system and essentially have the
consumer survivors be treating their
fellow consumer survivors now where they
are palpably destructive is that they
lobby in a fairly effective way against
involuntary commitment laws for the most
severely mentally ill and certainly as a
psychiatrist I mean no one wants to lock
up a patient against his or her will but
there are some individuals who are just
so dangerous to themselves or others
this has to be done and in particular
we'd like to be able to require that
some patients take their medication it's
well known
schizophrenic patients who are not
medicated are more dangerous and are
more prone to commit violent crime this
is a not a politically correct thing to
acknowledge but there is ample data to
support that that unmedicated they are
more dangerous than the average
population however we're not saying
certainly that bring back the the
asylums at the same scale they were in
the 50s you know certainly not
we'd like a lot of these folks to be
living independently and many of them
can if they take their medication the
problem is that maybe half up to half of
all people with schizophrenia don't even
know that they're sick so they don't
even know they have to take it and this
would be a legal mechanism for enforcing
them taking this medication so they can
live independently and safely
what's the politics of publishing this
book it's put out by the purchase group
the basic books
manone to publish a certain kind of book
did you have any trouble getting it out
I mean because this coming from the
point of view it is no in fact the other
I had Joanne Miller had been after me
since she 93 to write a book I used to
have a column in a monthly newspaper for
psychiatrists called psychiatric times
and I would always write about these
sorts of phenomenon so she knew where I
was my orientation what are your what
number of things are you involved in
that we haven't talked about presidency
how much of your time is spent with the
methadone clinic now first very part
time I'm there about three half days a
week what else are you doing oh I'm also
a resident I'm a fellow excuse me at the
American Enterprise Institute and what
do they want you to do what's that job
like well that's probably the greatest
job you could have I'm on a two-year
fellowship it's not over yet
and basically the the charge has been to
pursue whatever seems interesting to me
I mean I'm certainly I'm in their
category of social welfare and they they
do divide up obviously the scholars into
areas so I'm in Social Welfare
and I believe within that there's
individual and social responsibility so
I'm in that how do you get that how'd
you get that position
well actually president of AEI Chris
DeMuth I'd known him for a few years
just through mutual friends and them
just a lot of friends that I had
happened to be scholars there so I got
to meet him and I'd written a monograph
for him in 97 on drug treatment so he
got to know my work and then he gave me
a small grant to help support this and
so just three years of knowing him and
him getting to know my work now when you
walk in a meeting these meetings of all
these groups that you talk about in here
what are their reaction to you when they
see you I mean you are you among friends
or do people say oh oh here she comes
she's out to get us actually the
reaction has been among a lot of my
colleagues very positive as you can
imagine most people are people of common
sense and but a lot of folks feel and
inhibited about expressing my
reservations as I do in one of my
chapters for example about affirmative
action in medical school although a lot
of people are very concerned about it
and they their reaction is thank
goodness somebody said this and in fact
that was really one of my major goals in
writing at in addition to to describing
these trends I really wanted to
emboldened my colleagues and it turns
out that I hadn't realized this ahead of
time but probably the single
constituency natural constituency of
this book is public health professionals
and I've spoken to a number of Dean's
and schools of Public Health and others
who were extremely supportive and rather
relieved that this is now being talked
about I've of course gotten the
requisite you know hate mail as well and
been called by I think I was called the
most dangerous psychiatrist in America
although I think Hannibal Lecter is more
you do get you do that get into a lot of
discussion about affirmative action in
just today what's the law you mean
medical schools i mean medical schools
yeah there was the law the Bakke case
believe that was 1978 just ruled that
race could not be a sole criterion for
admission it's certainly part of the the
criteria used you would have thought
that when prop 209 passed in California
it would have had a big effect on racial
preferences it had an effect on the on
the number of applicants minority
applicants that applied to medical
schools it did have that effect but it
didn't have much of an effect at all in
fact I think it's fair to say it had no
effect on the double standard that was
used and in admissions and that double
standard has been going on ever since
Bakke and is going strong today and is
is endorsed I think very forthrightly by
many of the organizations within
medicine especially the Association of
American Medical College if you're white
black Asian whatever your your
background is and you want to go to med
school do they do do they differentiate
beti do you come in at a lower grade now
yeah can you is that legal
you know I I'm involved actually in a
reverse discrimination case right now as
an expert witness a student at the it
was challenging the University of
Maryland for exactly those practices I I
don't see how it can be legal but it's
it's it's ongoing and there's ample data
and much of it from the AAMC assuming I
am saying oh so C ation of American
Medical Colleges whose which support
racial preferences but ample data from
them they've been collecting it
meticulous data sets for years showing
in fact that there is a quite a
discrepancy between the scores the MCAT
scores Medical College Admission test
scores and grade point averages
of minorities who apply versus white and
Asian students who apply what happens
when you know someone gets into Medical
School and they have a less lesser score
and what happens to their do they get
out of medical school on the same
percentage of the others do yeah that's
good well good question of course they
probably don't there's a fair amount of
data showing that the failure rates on
the boards one takes two take two series
of boards medical schools four years
long there's a board after the first two
years and then after the second two
years the failure rates are multiple
times higher for the minority students
who were admitted with the poorer grades
that's very important to distinguish
between of course minorities admitted
with good grades competitively they do
fine just perfectly fine but those who
are underprepared at admission have much
higher failure rates on these tests they
take longer to graduate there is a
higher dropout rate and they're more
likely to have problems as residents if
they go on to the next phase there's a
footnote and I'm I've underlined so I
you we may be missing some important
points that you'll remember the
percentage of black and Hispanic
students getting Bachelor of Science
degrees has remained constant as have
those racist percentages of college
graduates ell at Cleveland personal
communication with the author January 6
no one really understands why medical
school is relatively unpopular among
these students perhaps some are
discouraged by the high educational debt
that will they will assume by the loss
of or by the loss of physician autonomy
in the world of managed care do they
really think about those kind of things
I think some people do I don't know if
that they I got that information from
the a I'm seeing I don't know if they
derive that through any kind of formal
survey or they're just inferring but
managed care certainly has had an
influence on the attitudes of certainly
practicing physicians who say they
wouldn't do it again well what what did
you find about all of us about going to
people that look like us as doctors I
mean the blacks want to go to blacks and
Asians to Asians and whites the whites
question well that is in fact the
rationale for racial preferences in
medical school which is to say it's a
little different than from affirmative
action racial brought I mean there's
racial preferences not firm ative action
affirmative action I'm all in favor of
which is outreach but as far as that is
the justification for racial preferences
in medical school that the only way we
will close the so-called health gap or
the fact for example that we have higher
infant mortality rate in
african-american babies and higher death
rates from higher incidence of diabetes
and and heart disease and and so on is
if we have more african-american doctors
which is different from the rationales
for racial preferences other places
there it's more principled even though I
personally don't agree with those
principles that they're the principles
of compensating for past injustice or
for diversity for diversity's sake but
in medical schools it's it's practical
and one would think it could be
empirically tested but I try to look at
proxies for an empirical approach in
other words what patients say do
patients really want to see two minority
patients really care that much the best
survey I could find there there were
several the best one I found was from
the Commonwealth Fund and it has done a
few years ago interviewed 4,000 patients
from every ethnic group imaginable and
asked them a series of very detailed
nested questions why do you choose your
doctor this sort of thing and they were
in one question they gave patients 13
possible reasons they could use to
choose a doctor ranging from convenience
of office location to he was my race and
and in almost every well an African
Americans and Hispanics a little less so
and Asians that was that right last
whether or not it was the same race and
they asked patients they asked a subset
of people for example who changed
doctors why did you change and only 2%
of them said so I could get a doctor of
my same race
the highest the highest percentage I
found was in it was in smaller studies I
thought not quite as well done but we're
up to twenty five percent of
african-americans for example said they
preferred a black doctor interestingly
and that study twelve percent of
african-americans explicitly said they
did not want a black doctor but
nevertheless maybe one in four so there
may be some preferences I'm also for
people of course exerting their
preferences how much federal money is
involved in this whole issue we're
talking about how much can be influenced
from this government in this town well
in terms of the consumer survivors we
talked about a lot because they and
that's why I wrote about them otherwise
who would care except that they leverage
their influence with federal dollars
they are largely supported through HHS
and that could stop overnight depending
on who takes over the lead agency there
which is called Samsa substance abuse
and mental health services
administration what kind of money do
they get probably um adding up I'm even
guessing here I proud I don't think it's
even more than fifteen million dollars
at ten million dollars so you know in
terms of big money it's not that big
money but it is leveraged fairly
effectively these consumer survivors try
to reach patients and hospitals patients
who've been discharged and try to
encourage them often not to take
medication as I said do some pretty
heavy lobbying and I found that
politicians are especially uninformed
about the kinds of interventions that
are needed for the severely mentally ill
and terrified of course of seeming as if
to violate civil rights you know by by
recalling the the era of the asylum
where there were some abuses certainly
on the back you book you have some
endorsements one of them is uh someone
who would not be considered a
conservative Republican Wendy kaminer
right
she writes feminists and other liberals
who have long protested the medical
professions right-wing biases should
heed so tells well argued critique of
the p c-- left-wing Medus
how did you get her to write that I
actually been a fan of Wendy commoners
for ever since she wrote I'm
dysfunctional you're a dysfunctional
actually she's a libertarian I think
she'd call her that herself that as
opposed to a liberal and she's basically
someone who respects data when data
exists and so I asked her what's your
goal in life where you go after wins
when is your a AEI fellowship over it's
over in the fall of 2002
so what then what do you want to do well
I'd like to do I think what I'm doing
now but at higher levels of visibility
and influence I I have thought about
returning at the same time though I have
thought about working with schizophrenic
patients again and devoting more of my
time to clinical work I'm maybe you've
once interviewed someone named fuller
Tory he's a psychiatrist
actually he's local and schizophrenia
researcher it's a lot of influence on
policies written some wonderful books
and he has started a group called the
treatment Advocacy Center it's located
in Arlington and it's efforts are
directed towards reforming these
commitment laws but but with that
background I have thought of working
with that group to perhaps developing a
a model kind of Asylum I realize that's
a word now that that has so much baggage
but a very benign one for the most
severely mentally ill that could be a
model and it would be residential and it
would be it would have elements that
actually borrow from some of the days of
Dorothea Dix of the moral treatment of
the mentally ill aware and was quite
dignified actually that the patient's
had working farms they worked with
animals they were they were
self-sustaining and that kind of an
environment plus the medications we have
today which are far more sophisticated I
think could make for a very humane
setting for that small minority of
severely mentally ill people who just
can't live independently here's what the
cover of the book looks like PCM D
political correctness is corrupting
medicine by Sally Satele MD thank you
very much for joining us thank you